dadans le noir. Depuis au moins
mimidi, les habitants sont
prprivés d'électricité.
U Un problèmeme de taille pour
cece citoyen, qui habite
auau 11e étage de son immeuble.
LoLorsque l'ascenceur est
hohors d'usage raconte-t-il,
ilil ne peut se rendre jusqu'à n
apappartement et doit souvent se
rérésoudre à dorormir dans son .
AÀ l'origine de cette coupure,
unune importante pénurie de mazt
ququi empêchche les deux plus
grgrandes centrales électriques
dede fonctionner.
SOSOFIA AMARA, collaboration
spspéciale à B Beyrouth, Liban
- - Le Liban est un pays
enen faillite et donc il n'a pas
dede devise pour se procurer
l'l'or noir qu'il nécessite pour
fafaire marcher ces centrales.
- - Depuis des mois, le pays
coconnait des rationnements
d'd'électricité draconniens. Mas
cecette fois-ci tout le monde et
totouché, mêmeme les commercant.
" "La coupure est mauvaises
susur tous les fronts", dit ce
prpropriétaire d'un magasin,
"e"elle nous empêche e d'obteniu
d'd'utiliser les outils dont nos
avavons besoin pour travailler".
C'C'est que les services privés,
ququi fournissent normalement
l'l'électricité à l leurs abonns
enen temps de panne,
sosont eux aussi à c court.
- - Le gouvernement libanais,
foformé il y a quelques semaine,
a a indiqué que l'électricité
nene serait pas de retour
avavant lundi au plus tôt.t.
P Pour la suite des choses,
ilil s'est tourné vers les pays
vovoisins pour tenter de
s's'approvisionner en pétrole.
L'L'Irak a déjà proromis d'en
didistribuer en échange
dede services médicaux.
LeLe ministre des Affaires
ététrangères s de l'Iran promet
dede continuer à e en livrer au.
DéDéjà, lele mouvement chiite
HeHezbollah facilite le transpot
d'd'importantes quantités
dede pétrole iranien au Liban.
UnUne participation critiquée pr
dedes observateurs internationa,
ququi accuse le groupe armé
dede profiter de la crise pour
crcréer un état dans l'état.
I Ici Alexie André-Bélisle,
R Radio-Canada, Montréal.